le festival breton les vieilles charrues
fait son retour à carhaix mêmes lieux
mais nouvelle ambiance avec pass
sanitaire obligatoire et c'est l'unique
laventure continue pour le plus grand
festival français qui a commencé comme
ça tout le monde bat landreau a
participé à la construction de cet
éphémère port de pêche
les enfants des écoles primaires ont
peint plusieurs fresques sur le thème
des formats rhin les dames du troisième
âge ont quant à elle réalisé 300 mètres
de guirlandes en forme de flotteurs en
1993 pour sa deuxième édition la fête a
lieu à l'endos un petit village breton
elle a des allures de kermesse c'est
l'idée d'un groupe dave ce qu'on essaye
surtout de faire c'est une grande fête
populaire essayer de rassembler
l'ensemble du centre-bretagne autour
d'un thème
on a décidé de de prendre d'abord des
facteurs de la belle époque des
tracteurs qui date des années 50 qui
vont descendre du bourg qui donc
représente le monde rural qui vont
descendre donc jusqu'ici au site du
stang le port de pêche
très vite des groupes de musique locaux
s'invite à la fête
le festival commence à se faire
remarquer en 1995 la ville de carhaix
invitait les organisateurs à s'installer
sur son champ de foire trois jours de
fête musique et théâtre de rue avec en
tête d'affiché les blues brothers seller
silencers près de dix mille personnes
sont attendues sur les trois jours pour
ce festival qui se veut éclectique et
pas cher 30 francs la soirée un prix
rarement pratiquée pour ce genre
d'événement
mille personnes en 1995 et le succès va
se confirmer chaque année jamais carrés
n'avait connu telle affluence jusqu'à 2
heures d'attentes dans les 10 km de
bouchons à l'entrée de la ville la
programmation éclectique participe aussi
à la renommée de l'événement
des artistes du monde entier débarquent
dans la ville bretonne en 2001 les
organisateurs vivait cette réussite en
toute décontraction en pas la tête on
fait les choses sérieusement sans se
prendre au sérieux ces sept jours était
une devise du festival et le public
ressent ces choses là autre volonté des
organisateurs maintenir et développer
l'économie de la région
une aubaine pour les commerçants du coin
c'est une bouffée d'oxygène pour les
finances est prenable pour la peine pour
le moral le reste de l'année les
affaires marchent moins bien plus en
plus calme depuis sa création les
associations locales participent aussi à
la fête
là tous les serveurs sont bénévoles et
membres d'associations locales pour les
remercier le festival va verser
plusieurs milliers d'euros à leurs
causes respectives
georges et ses amis ont pu rénover leurs
chapelles les vieilles charrues ou
l'histoire d'une kermesse devenu en 29
ans un festival de renom international
cette année cinquante mille festivaliers
sont attendus contre 270 milles en 2019
[Musique]